des visiteurs ébahis par tant de
modernité on est ici totalement dans
l'esprit de la foire de tours 100 ans
c'est l'âge qu'on lui fait aujourd'hui
ce rendez vous incontournable et
pourtant beaucoup plus anciens il ya
toujours eu des foires de tours depuis
l'époque gallo romaine mais réellement
la création des grandes foires de tours
c'est sous françois 1er en 1645 et
l'autorisent la création de deux foires
frange à tour s'avère d'efforts exempte
d'impôts royal pas de taxes et donc une
activité commerciale démultipliée elle
occupera différentes places de la ville
et deviendra à la fin du 19e siècle une
exposition de matériel agricole de tout
premier plan
le maire de tours en 1921 camille
chautemps décide de renforcer le concept
de la foire de tout regarder la foire
traditionnelle hérité de xvième siècle
renforcer le caractère agricole depuis
1979 mais surtout créé à la foire de
tours une dimension très attractive de
loisirs de spectacles de culture pour
permettre à la foire de devenir un
élément attractif bien entendu
économique mais aussi festif une petite
révolution il ya un nouvel élan pour une
foire toujours plus attractive à la
grande semaine comme on l'appelle
désormais on vient rêver devant les
dernières innovations
le rendez-vous prend une ampleur telle
qu'il devient impossible de le laisser
se dérouler au centre ville le maire de
tours jean royer prend la décision en
1964 de transférer la foire de tours du
centre ville où on ne peut plus se tenir
parce qu'elle se développe de manière
trop importante et de l'installer sur le
site de rochepinard qu'il vient
d'aménager dans le cadre de la
construction de la vallée du cher des
équipements flambant neuf dans un
urbanisme totalement redessiné la foire
de tours modernes et festive prend le
visage qu'on lui connaît aujourd'hui
alors c'est vrai que cette année pour
cause de pandémie les visiteurs ne sont
pas tous venus au rendez vous mais
durant sa longue existence la foire de
tours a connu bien d'autres vicissitudes
gageons qu'elle sera cette fois ci
encore trouvé le moyen de rebondir